翻訳: Kyoko Kamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
みなさん ダブルダッチっていうのは
ご存知でしょうか？
こういうものですね（笑）はい
２本の縄を使って
２人でそれを回して
中でいろいろな技を
やっていくというのが
ダブルダッチです
もう一度質問させてください
この会場でこのダブルダッチのことを
なんとなくで結構です
知っていた方はどれくらい
いらっしゃいますか？
もうほとんどの方が知っていますね（笑）
ありがとうございます
ではこのダブルダッチ
実際に見た事がある方
どれくらいいらっしゃいますか？
こうなると半分くらいになるんですね
そういう風に知っているけれども
実際に見たことがない方に
よく私は質問されます
「君はダブルダッチ回すほうなの？
飛ぶほうなの？」
というふうによく聞かれます
頷いていらっしゃる方多いので
そういう風に思われた方も
いらっしゃると思います
ここで実際に私がダブルダッチを
やっている映像を用意しましたので
少しご覧いただければと思います
[著作権の都合上映像のみでお伝えしております]
見ていただいた通りですね
ダブルダッチって
回すほう 飛ぶほう
入れ替わり立ち替わりで
両方やるのがダブルダッチなんです
ご覧いただいた通り
私はダブルダッチをしていて
いろんなところでパフォーマンス[や]
ショーといったものをしています
今日もいつものダブルダッチを
しているメンバーは
九州の熊本の方で
ダブルダッチをやっています
僕はここにいます
ただ平日は 一会社員として
サラリーマンをしています
なので 休日はダブルダッチでパフォーマー
平日はサラリーマンといった形の
二足の草鞋を履いている状態です
そんな私の体験を通じて
一つのアイデアを
紹介させていただきます
人はいろんな「場」を持っています
その「場」に常に行き来している
状態でございます
例えば家で過ごしている「場」
仕事をしているときの「場」
恋人と一緒に過ごしているときの「場」
学校で勉強したり
部活動に励んでいるときの「場」
いろんな「場」があると思います
さらにその「場」というのは
自分の居心地が良い
気分が盛り上がる「場」と
居心地が悪い
気分だだ下がりの「場」に
分けることができると思います
もちろんどちらにも属さない
といったものはあると思いますが
大半の方がこの気分が盛り上がる「場」に
居続けることができればいいな
と思っていると思います
私の場合 ダブルダッチー
休日でダブルダッチをしているときがー
この気分の盛り上がる「場」で
平日の仕事をしているときが
面白いこともなく
気分が下がり続ける状態でした
当たり前なんですけれども
１週間のうち ほとんどが平日ですよね
もう全く誰が考えたんでしょうね？
非常に残念です（笑）
そういう風に気分が下がる「場」
にいることが多くなると
精神的にもすごく
しんどくつらくなってきます
かといってその気分が下がる「場」を
切り捨ててしまうと
様々な問題が出てくるかと思います
例えば私は独身なんですが
もし結婚をしていて
子供がいるっていう状態で
気分が下がるからという理由で
突然明日から仕事へ行かない
仕事を辞めるってなれば
周りから猛反対されると思います
ではどうすればいいんでしょう？
ここで少し私自身の話を
させていただきます
今年でダブルダッチ始めて
10年目になるんですが
もともと大学に入ってから
ダブルダッチを始めました
なんとなく楽しそうだな
という理由で始めました
まあ少しだけ
「ちょっとかっこ良くて
女の子にもてるんじゃないか」
という理由もありました
もう一度言います 「少しだけ」です（笑）
ただ やっていくうちに
ダブルダッチの魅力に
どんどんと取り込まれて
気がつけば 「世界大会で優勝するんだ」
という目標ができるくらい
のめり込んでいました
それくらい学生時代は
ダブルダッチのことしか頭になく
夢中で取り組んでいました
そして学生時代 最後の
世界大会が懸かった大会に出ました
そこで見事負けてしまいました
目標だった世界大会に出場することが
できませんでした
そのまま大学を卒業して
普通に就職活動をして
就職することになりました
ただ それが悔しいという思いと
ダブルダッチが好きだ
という思いが強くあったため
働きながらでも
ダブルダッチをやろうという風に
ダブルダッチプレーヤーで
居続けることを選びました
ただ ダブルダッチの存在が
すごく大きくあったため
どんどんと仕事が辛くなっていき
休日のダブルダッチをするだけが
楽しみの日々を過ごしていました
そんな日が続き
私は一度会社に行けなくなって
家にしばらく
引きこもった時期もありました
しばらくして 会社には
行けるようになったんですが
完全に休日やプライベートと仕事を
全く別物としてとらえるようになりました
妥協して過ごしていました
そこで私にダブルダッチをやっていて
転機が訪れました
夢だった世界大会に
出場することができました
左から２番目が僕なんですけれども
まあ嬉しそうな顔をしてますよね
少し見えにくいんですけれども
下の方にトロフィーがずらっと並んでます
そうなんです 世界大会でも
優勝することができました
（拍手）ありがとうございます
それと同時期ぐらいに会社でも
自分の部署異動がありました
この２つの出来事がきっかけで
私は変わりました
どう変わったのかというと
まず社内の人 グループ会社も含めて
自分のダブルダッチの出来事を
話すようになりました
するとその人が 周りの人にも
ダブルダッチの話を
するようになりました
気分が良いです
調子に乗った私は 社外でも
お客さん先や取引先に
同じようにダブルダッチの話を
するようになりました
すると同じように
「あの会社にはダブルダッチの
世界チャンピオンがいるんだ」とか
そういう形で どんどんと
広がっていきました
さらに社外向けの広報にも
取り上げられるようになりました
どんどんと自分の認知度っていうのが
広がっていくのがわかりました
すると会社にいること[や]
仕事の話をしているっていうのが
どんどんと楽しくなってきたんです
さらにそれに関係するような仕事とか
自分がやりたいと思えるような仕事も
どんどんと生まれてきました
今ではあんなに仕事ってしんどい
辛いと思っていたものが
「仕事って楽しい」という風に
今は思えるようになってきました
仕事って楽しいと思えるように
なってきました（笑）はい
この自分が元々テンションのー
気分の下がる場だったものが
今はテンションー
気分が盛り上がる場に今はなっています
そもそもこの気分が盛り上がる場
といったものは
どういったものなんでしょうか？
逆に気分が盛り下がる場というところは
気分が盛り上がる場には何があるのか？
というのを考えてみたら
いいかもしれません
気分が上がる場には
自分のことが好きな人や良き理解者
そして自分のやりたいことや
やりたいものというのが
その場にはあります
それがたくさんあればあるほど
その場が自分にとって
気分のいい場所になります
逆に気分の下がる場っていうのはその逆ですね
では気分が下がる場を
気分が上がる場に変えるためには
どうすればいいのか？というと
そこにいる「人」とか「もの」
「こと」っていうのを
自分にとって気分の上がる「人」や「もの」に
変えていく必要があります
それは具体的にはどうすればいいのか？というと
私がしたみたいにそこにいる人たちに
自分がやりたいことや していること
夢中になっていること
得意なことっていうのを
どんどんと発信するんです
するとそこにいる人たちは
共感をしてくれたり応援してくれたり
そういう人たちが
どんどんと増えてきます
すると自分でも知らなかった
「こうこうこういう風な
夢中になれるものがあれば」
「こんなことをしたら
もっと面白いんじゃないか？」
といった形で周りの人たちが
教えてくれるんです
与えてくれるんです
自分では気づかなくても
周りの人が与えてくれるんですね
そうすることで
気分の上がる場に変わることになります
今では気分の下がる場だったものが
上がる場になるんですね
私は私にとって 気分の下がる場
というのが仕事の場でした
みなさんにとっては
どういったものがあるでしょう？
例えば課題の多い授業があったり
新しい職場にいって
なかなかうまくいかなかったり
いろんな場合が考えられます
たとえ今は
気分の下がる場がなかったとしても
今後
転職とか就職とか
引っ越しそして結婚とか
人生の転機が訪れる時に
気分が下がる場っていうのが
出てくる可能性はあります
ただ その場に出くわしても
どんどんと自分を出してみてください
すると意外と気分の上がる場に
それは変わるんです
自分が熱中できることや
得意なことがあるのに
それを出さないなんて
非常にもったいないです
閉じ込めるのではなくて
どんどんと自分を出してみてください
今よりももっとたくさんの
気分が上がる世界が
いっぱいの未来が
待っていると思います
ありがとうございました（拍手）